Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast and
I yes,
checking it on.
Yeah.
Oh,
that was a good one.
The lovely Nia hidden,
you know,
give me,
give me a microphone here.
I got to pass this through because it was,
the wires are all cross to,
oh,
I got the wires crossed.
The wires are crossed.
We're sitting here.
Is that better?
Yup.
Me and the lovely Nia we have on.
The reason he is here is I hit,
we have a huge announcement to make that as of this morning.
Yeah,
me and I die.
Yes.
Became two people right?
That yes.
Had corn,
beef hash for breakfast.
Absolutely.
We are so proud and we're so happy and we just want to thank everybody for your
support,
your support over the last few months and for your thoughts during this
difficult time maybe isn't here yet.
So I've been,
yeah,
I become like a Sitcom Dad.
Just fucking hanging out at the house where my big fucking socks.
Bill's got big fuzzy socks on.
Yeah.
That's one new thing.
That's right.
You got to Colton?
Yeah,
because I get hot.
Yeah we have hardwood floors and he is fucking walking around more pregnant than
anybody I've ever got DMC.
So it's like she could be standing in Antartica being like,
can we put on the AC now I'm over here fucking chilly willy.
So I got on my uh,
cell pregnant.
I'm just like a human tea kettle.
I am short and stout.
You all baby,
you're all paying me.
You look good to me.
Um,
yeah.
Thank you.
Anyways,
uh,
so we're sitting out here on a rainy fucking Sunday.
It's been raining cats and dogs out here.
And uh,
did he say rainy Sunday?
Did I say Sunday?
I don't know.
It feels like a Sunday.
It's a fucking Thursday.
Whatever.
Pouring outside.
You know what pissed me off yesterday on the news,
some fucking idiot.
Like they announced out here in California,
they said the drought is over.
Does cause it rains?
Well now because it rained so much that this flooding,
but like yeah,
this shit's gonna stop and then this,
this is going to have to last us for like four years.
Cause you know,
the next feet like,
well how much does it have to rain for it to no longer be a drought?
That's my question.
Well I think just the mere fact that it's raining mean that there's no,
no,
the water levels in all the reservoirs.
I believe I'm just would guests that this they have to get to a certain level
because when I did my bus tour,
burning my own hole in the fucking California ozone,
sure.
When,
uh,
we went by all these big reservoirs that were for,
you know,
drinking water or just even people just ride boats around or whatever.
Like you could see the waterline.
I mean it was like to like,
you know,
a brownstone in New York,
picture like two or three of those stacked on top of each other that low and it
looks like it was a half mile across to me was fucking ridiculous.
Yeah,
it was,
it was terrifying to be honest with you.
So evidently it's gotten up to an level,
so now everyone's going to start taking fucking long showers.
You know what I mean?
Just kills me out here.
Every time when it starts to fucking rain and you wash all,
you watch all that water going down the La River,
that goes all the way down to Marina del Rey,
I believe in.
Then it just goes out into the ocean.
It's like,
why don't you capture that somehow and save it all that runoff.
Yeah.
I mean I think environmentalist would like that to happen.
It's a very complicated
lost.
Kids couldn't have books in schools anymore.
If we captured it.
The raid one,
we did that,
then we'd have to cut this and I dunno.
It sounds like,
it seems like it's complicated.
Maybe it's not.
I don't know.
Yeah,
you have.
You have no energy today.
I can hear it in my voice.
You have like rainy day energy.
I have rainy day in pregnant as fuck energy.
Rainy Day in pregnant.
Oh,
brings me down.
Well,
why don't you just fucking have the kid just fucking,
you know.
Oh,
I wish I could.
I wish I could have it right now.
Yeah.
You know what?
You know what's funny is I've been like joking about this on stage is the level
that people have been trying to,
uh,
every day I get a text,
it'll say,
did the kid come yet?
And I'll say,
no,
I mean the followup Texas,
are you nervous?
It's like,
well,
I wasn't,
I was sitting here relaxed.
Like they just get you on edge.
And I'm just like,
it's been this great process where I'm just like,
wow man,
I always listened to people.
I need to stop doing that because it doesn't help you if they just think I was
joking on stage like they were getting you like,
you know when you get a dog all excited,
like you want to go say,
how do you want to go into that?
Like that's what they're doing to your like,
is the baby here?
Are you nervous?
You excited and uh,
am again and you're freaking out like three or four attacks a day for like the
past three days.
It's like,
no,
Amy's not here.
Yeah.
You sound like you drank some of it.
What's that?
Drank.
You sound like your lien.
Is that what the kids are doing nowadays with the fucking cough syrup and their
Irish spring that they take a cheese grater and they fucking Irish spring.
That's one of my favorite things to dirty sprite.
That's where future calls it.
I like when you go on least for these fucking people on the Internet and they
show you how to make it,
cause I was sitting,
it was a comedian,
I got to know what's going on.
Oh,
did you look online to see how it's man?
Yeah,
it's literally spray it and like Cody and like prescription and then take like a
car.
Someone put up a jolly rancher or some shit in there.
But like if you just look at the ingredients on the back of the fucking thing.
Yeah,
yeah.
Like uh,
I gotta hand it to this generation.
All these generations.
Every time you think like,
you know,
wow.
Like,
like I was saying,
my generation there was crack babies and I'm just like,
okay,
that's it.
That's the end.
That's as fucked up as you as you're going to see.
Like human beings do things like,
like as a parent,
I wouldn't be able to be shocked like you're doing what right.
Then came meth heads,
which literally looked like walking dead people.
They're not zombies,
but they're not real people anymore.
They have like fucking,
they like when I would do gigs out in the Midwest,
you know,
Iowa and in further west into those states,
celebrities go to buy a log cabin and buy a fucking pretend they own a grizzly
bear outfit.
Right?
You go out there and they had like this before and after pictures of people on
meth.
Yeah.
And I was just like,
Holy Shit.
That made,
that blew my fucking mind.
And now looking at these guys,
I mean,
I guess this isn't as bad as math,
but just watching beings will always find a way to get high though new creative
ways to get high.
That's just kinda how it goes.
Don't you think?
But I'm going to sound like an old man here.
What,
what was wrong with what the fuck we did?
You can just drink a couple of beers.
I mean,
what's that?
That fucking drink that they're drinking.
That's like shit homeless people do or like,
like full on alcoholics and people will not fucking give you like money for
booze anymore and you just don't have it that that's what they used to do.
They go and they start drinking nyquil.
Yeah,
cause prescription and any of that stuff is really like,
I dunno,
I've never drank that kind of stuff before,
but it's supposed to mimic the feel of opioids.
I thought opioids,
opioids,
opiates,
you mean?
Oh No opioid.
Is that correct?
I think that's some bump on your ass.
No,
that's a hemorrhoid.
I thought opiates,
so that's opiates.
Opiates and hemorrhoids is also a word.
It is,
I think is that when you take like the Qtip lace with the Shit and you put it in
your ass.
I don't know why you are assessed with the ass.
No,
no.
There was a thing that these kids were doing.
They were soaking something.
I swear to God,
I went down a rabbit hole.
How these kids get high.
There was this fucking thing they were doing.
They were taking something acute dip or something and there was soaking it in
this shit that got you high and then they'd stick it in their ass because
there's a thin membrane there.
I believe it.
Yeah.
Like how people blow coke up each others ass and stuff.
No.
Yeah,
that's a thing that is not a thing.
I know.
You know what?
I'll go with the fucking Q tip up the ass.
No,
it totally as a thing.
Hang on a sec.
That is not a fucking thing.
The old coke in the ass.
It's just,
yeah,
just picture what that looks like.
What are you,
your cup it in your hand and then you can go spread it wider.
Wider and yeah,
no fucking way.
Like a straw.
A funnel in the Enos.
Really.
And how well do you know this person?
I do.
We've been friends for a while,
right?
You know,
I've seen you drink drinks.
You use a strives Australia,
right?
That's not really crazy.
You know,
and we both have acids.
So
I got this bag of coke.
Hear me out.
Just hear me out.
Just sit out,
sit out.
Just listening.
I'm not taking my pants off.
I was just adjusting my belt.
Listen.
Alright,
coke.
This is going to be on my fucking search engine now.
Next time I go to an apple store,
coke up.
Yes.
Up The bum.
A off the are.
So it's even in England.
I got cocaine blown up my ass.
So you don't have to.
What?
Oh,
that's advice article.
Of course it is.
Okay.
Wait,
anal use rectal administration.
It's also drugs forum.com.
So
don't put cocaine in your,
but people that said Reddit,
uh,
live week.
Dot Cong man blows cocaine up a woman's ass.
Yeah.
Was he trying to numb it before he stuck his fatty and their thing?
So okay.
Wait as well.
You don't encyclopedia dramatica investigate it more.
Just know that it's a thing that exists.
All right,
well then I got to look mine up.
Well,
I've got to read the article here.
All right.
This is what you need.
Some sort of fucking a kitchen knife.
Wait,
wait.
Let's not tell people how to do it.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
I can say,
okay,
this isn't real.
Nia.
When the Internet was suddenly a buzz with rumors that getting a friend to blow
coke up your ass with the straw was worth the trouble.
I had to see if I'd been doing it all wrong.
After all,
blow doesn't come with instructions.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Get to the fucking point.
All right.
I don't know.
There's not gonna be a video.
This is a,
okay.
Okay.
Uh,
I know it's funny.
I said hoping the conversation would cover,
but I just wanted to understand the possible health effects on a more
fundamental low.
Okay.
So he called somebody physician's viewpoint in a very nice woman named Kate
spoke to me.
I asked her about it and she fell silent.
He said,
I know.
It's funny.
I said,
I was hoping.
She says,
it's more sad actually.
He said,
Oh yeah,
that's the word I should have used.
Said.
Overall.
Kate was extremely helpful and promised to contact all the gastro,
uh,
set mineralogist still the Internet had spoken.
I had to try it.
Not that,
that the de this guy.
Okay,
I'm going just go with the pictures now.
He's got the spoon.
He sticks it in a vile.
All right.
In the end,
my high was no more significant than when I opt for the more orthodox approach.
All right,
so people are doing it because it was the other thing.
The thing I was talking about,
rave,
let me look this up.
Rave drugs.
Yeah.
Ass Search.
Somebody's got their booty eating at an all in an American festival.
Strange happenings regarding Edm festivals.
Raves and drugs.
Yeah.
Strange happenings regarding Edm Festival raves and drugs.
Them.
Dot Dot,
dot.
Them and going to eat their ass.
Not really and not what people are thinking.
How to smuggle in gear to a concert.
Jesus Christ shaking her ass at a rave party.
Wicked woman.
I don't know why.
Right kill.
Come off of this topic.
This is getting weird.
Let me just get weird.
We're not doing it.
We're just researching towns in the San Diego.
Sure.
I'm moving up to Los Angeles.
Oh,
is I saw something online about that.
Yeah.
They finally,
they're returning home where they belong.
They were the Los Angeles chargers for one season.
The first year.
The AFL,
they're back where they started here.
They come round again.
Hey,
where did nick go?
It's almost like she's having a contraction.
Um,
dude,
you've got to ask yourself as a San Diego charger fan,
after all the fucking heartache and everything,
he just went through and now they're going to fucking walk out on you.
You know,
you've got to be asking yourself like,
what,
what was that off?
What was that all for?
You know?
Right.
I actually am back as much as they hated as much as they hated the fucking,
the Patriots and Tom Brady and I had a horrible fan experience when I went down
and I were patriots hats,
not real.
And I'm realizing how much they hated us.
Um,
I just don't,
I just,
I actually felt bad for them as fence because it wasn't that they lost,
it's the way they lost.
They did the old Boston red sox thing.
What we used to do before we started winning all the championships was,
uh,
we couldn't just have the decency to just suck like the cubs all those years,
you know,
the cubs just sucked.
They had like two errors to Eric Games,
one of the early eighties and then they had the fucking one where they blamed
that,
that fucking a little nerd,
you know,
rather than the other six people that stood up around them.
Also trying to catch the ball.
They had to,
to heartbreakers.
That was it.
Other than that,
it was a big keg party.
Everybody standing there with their shirts off.
They all live in Wrigleyville.
They get money that they're not sympathetic people.
You know what I mean?
Um,
but charge offense,
you know what I mean?
They just like,
they had that fucking old ass God damn stadium.
They wrote it out.
They were down there.
They came close in like 95 got their fucking asses kicked was at 95 and 94 when
Steve Young got the monkey take it off his back.
Wasn't that what it was near?
Oh yeah.
Steve Young who claimed the Patriots should have all of their championships
taken away because of spy gate.
One of the dumbest things I ever heard.
It's like,
yeah,
that's Great Steve.
It's a brand new rule.
It was illegal for one game.
So when it wasn't illegal because we were doing it back then,
then they should get charged for it when the rest of the league was also doing
it.
Alright.
Whatever.
So welcome to La.
We went from no football teams to tune in.
Now.
How does that make you feel?
Are you excited?
No.
Yes,
no.
I'll say no.
I don't care.
I'm kind of um,
you know,
need to tap out in different,
you'd done now I'm okay.
You're okay.
You don't look like you're okay.
I can make it.
It's a good distraction.
All right.
For sure.
For all the guys out there and for the ladies who never been pregnant,
what does that feel like at this point?
If you guys are one on one?
I'm so fucking relaxed.
She's had so many of these goddamn things.
It's like somebody crying wolf.
Yeah.
Crying Wolf.
Now these are,
you know,
you should do to freak me out.
Yeah.
When I'm not there,
just throw a glass of water on the floor and just be like,
oh,
just watch me.
Someone had suggested that I do that to you on Twitter,
but I don't,
I'm not original.
I don't think that's a good idea.
Um,
yeah,
no.
These are called Braxton Hicks contractions.
They are getting you ready for actual real contractions and I have been having
them more and more frequently.
Yes.
Answered the question as I'm getting closer to answer what questions?
Like what does it feel like?
Oh,
it feels like an extreme tightening in your abdomen.
I'll relate it to a pain you've had before.
Get slugged in the shoulder and that's never happened to be having your big
brother grabbed you by one of your ankles and drag you back down the stairs.
What happened to me?
Uh,
this is the only way I can relate to it's launched in the ear.
It's like,
it's like someone is in your stomach,
stretching it out as tight as it can go and then it slowly goes back to normal
running into the living room cause you missed the big play.
Looking at the TV and running full speed into the coffee table.
Stomach first.
Sure.
Okay.
There we go.
I did that.
Yes,
I did that on Monday when I watch,
when I watched the Alabama Clemson game.
Now I know near as much.
You don't like football.
I know you heard me screaming when Clemson scored that last.
You were definitely screaming
I would be the worst announcer ever.
You know,
like the great answers have to be like,
do you believe in miracles?
Yes.
Or like he did it.
He did it fluidly.
Did it?
They have like something,
you know the shot heard round the world.
One of the fuck it was the giants win the pennant.
The job I just went like,
yeah,
you were going crazy there.
Yeah,
I saw it as like one of the Crimson,
call me d d.
Um,
I actually,
when I was watching that fucking that game I was uh,
I was actually happy for either team winning cause my,
my,
my hatred of Alabama is completely phony.
I'm not from down south.
You know,
I just picked Lsu because I thought that last miles was a guy who I thought he
was crazy eating grass and shit,
you know,
going forward on fucking field goals,
having the field goal kick of run down the fucking street and slippers scoring
touchdowns.
I was like,
Hey,
I'll fucking go with these guys.
You know?
So it just became fun to root against them.
But it was also,
I'm a big fan of history,
Nia and a,
he would've tied Paul Bear Bryant if he won another championship.
And I'm also lie head was saying that Alabama is overrated because the SCC was
weak and then out.
So then I was kind of rooting for Alabama to beat a team that just fucking beat
the shit out of the Ohio state buckeyes 31 to nothing.
Um,
I was kind of hoping for that.
But then also you've got to get a root for Clemson.
They're the underdog,
right?
Phenomenal.
This is how much of a Cleveland Guy,
okay.
Jason La had is,
well,
I love Jason.
Okay.
But he has the disease of being a Cleveland Sports Fan when fucking,
uh,
Clemson went up because what happened was Clemson scored and it looked like they
were gonna win the game.
And then Alabama went right down the field and gave him the old right there,
Fred.
And then Clemson came back when it looked like there was really no time left and
then they scored and then they want,
right.
So when Clemson went up and it looked like Alabama wasn't going to have enough
time to score,
Jason Texted me about their head coach saying he'll find a way to fuck this up.
And I just wrote back,
Jesus Christ,
Jason,
can you just believe?
And then sure enough,
Alabama goes down and scores a touchdown and then Jason writes to me,
you Clemson,
you lose some almost trying to look like you win some,
you lose some or something like that.
And then Clemson goes down against all of his fucking negative vibes.
They go ahead,
they scored the winning touchdown or you know what he says to me,
he goes out,
they should have won it last year.
She didn't want to last year two,
they finally win a championship.
That's what he says.
Um,
I don't know.
Classic Cleveland Guy.
Anyways.
Yeah.
Uh,
we're going to go see a double feature today,
Huh?
Yes.
You taking me to a,
what am I going to go?
See?
We're going to go see mood having a number one.
Yes.
All right.
That's the five one.
One rule.
So that's two within five minutes.
I know,
but this isn't a real contraction.
This is the lady who never had a baby.
So you guys do at the end of this fucking thing about all sitting here to baby
crying like,
man,
what the fuck?
Because I know this is,
they say,
you know,
you know when the contraction is real and it's like you got to know when to hold
them.
I don't think I'd be able to
hang out and hold a microphone.
The have a kid.
Yeah,
no.
When the podcast,
you nailed [inaudible] Joe babies sitting on.
So there'll be times
when a Braxton Hicks is done.
Right?
Exactly.
We're going to go see moonlight and they weren't going to see hidden figures.
And this is all dependent.
I mean,
hopefully,
yes,
I won't be mowed light on it and figures my water won't be breaking during any
of these.
I'll just this make bill woke day.
Ah,
it's just starting
trimester guy.
So I got to just agree with everything that she fucking said.
So I got to go see that.
And then I gotta go see hidden figures where you know they're going to do a
total overcorrection of fucking history and they're gonna have a bunch of guys
running around.
Like,
why don't wait,
what am I supposed to be a really good movie?
And I'm excited to see it.
I know.
And it's,
it's keyword based on a true story.
Carson in it.
Kevin fucking
[inaudible] and my garage and pneumonia who I love so much.
Remember when went to see her concert we saw before she was famous,
famous,
famous.
We saw when she was just famous.
That's right.
She's jumped around on the saddle shoes when she was opening for somebody.
Not know she closed.
No,
she opened for Jamie Lidell at the Avalon.
Don't you remember?
I had seen her in a magazine and I was like,
who is this?
And I listened to some of her music and I'm like,
that's cool.
And then the week of our wedding,
she was playing at the House of Blues and I went to go see her a couple of days
before our wedding and it was awesome.
And one with my maid of honor.
We took a picture together and we ended up hanging out with her.
And what did afterwards what?
What did you have to eat afterwards?
What?
What do you say?
You're just getting into a lot of detail here.
Oh,
well,
excuse me.
Sorry,
I'm,
I got cabin fever.
Knew I said yesterday,
but we watch it.
We watched,
I sat in the fucking laid in bed with you.
Yeah.
And we watched all those fucking game shows.
We,
we watch jeopardy.
Wait for everyone.
Oh,
first we watched the news.
We've turned into a real old couple.
We watched the news and then we will Trump yelling at that guy and CNN and then
we watch jeopardy news.
You're fake news.
I won't answer that.
Let her talk.
Don't be rude.
Jeopardy.
And then we watched a wheel of fortune.
Fortunate got boring.
They got rid of all their fucking,
they used to have the worst fucking prizes you had to pick from.
Right?
In the end they'd be,
it was always like for $600 I'll take the brass bed frame
for five 60 I'll take the grandfather clock.
So like old people,
Shit.
300 bucks.
I'll take the estate jewelry.
Oh my God.
Damn father clocks.
I'll take,
put the rest on a gift certificate.
How many people went bankrupt?
Every other fucking spent.
Yeah,
that nerdy black kid.
Every time you would get ahead,
every time Calvin will get ahead
and he didn't win in the,
Anna was so sad.
I mean he won,
but then he didn't get the final puzzle.
And I think all the Calvin,
we're winners that day.
Alright patch.
Say Jack is 70 years old.
Alex Tribec is 76 Alex Tribeca is under contract for another two years.
This is,
this was why my fucking add reacts when I watched the game show.
Cause after a while I can't watch those people excitedly yelling out letters.
Really see a say.
There is two C's.
You want to solve the puzzle or continue spinning?
I'm going to get tineas pain.
Three 50.
Is there an l?
Ooh,
I'm sorry.
There's no l Calvin spin the wheel.
I think I can get,
get,
get.
Fucking drove me insane.
And I can't even,
I never know what it says.
You can have everything but the vowels of pseudo care,
kitchen,
titty.
I could never understand.
I never know what the fuck it is.
You're really good at sports.
Jeopardy.
We watch some sports jeopardy this week.
We've been watching a lot of game shows.
That's true.
Yup.
Oh my God.
Before sports jeopardy.
Yeah.
The shit that doesn't matter in life.
I know everything about,
um,
speaking of which,
how about those Celtics?
Huh?
Sally had a tough one against the fucking raptors are the huskies.
Whatever the fuck they were doing.
Every he's doing,
they throw back fucking jerseys.
Um,
Jesus Christ.
I don't know one person's name on the Toronto Raptors,
but I do know DeRozen now.
Holy Shit.
That guy just,
he hit her.
I thought he kept saying the Rosa and of course I just kept thinking of Joe,
Joe,
Joe Rosen killed him.
He killed us on the raptors.
There's the Photoshop right there.
I want to see Joe Rosa.
We have to,
you can find a fucking picture of him where he kind of looks confident.
Um,
you know,
Joey put up,
put them in with that Toronto huskies fucking throwback,
that guy two rows and killed this man.
Finally when he scored like his 41st point,
I think he turned around and looked at our bench or at the crowd and it was,
I didn't even make me upset.
It's just like,
yeah,
dude,
the,
you couldn't,
you couldn't cover the guy.
We had a,
we fucking had a,
Toronto was
exactly,
we thought they were reflecting off the hook,
but that's a,
um,
that's,
you know,
that's where we're at.
We,
we finally fucking beat everybody else except for the people we're going to run
into in the late rounds of the playoffs.
So,
uh,
it's looking like the Celtics game went around or maybe too,
who knows?
Depending on,
uh,
but you know,
that was to become the second seat in the east,
which would have been sweet.
Right?
Cause this number two play 70.
You know this,
did you just fall asleep?
No,
no,
no bad.
No,
no,
no.
I feel you want to listen to me read out loud.
Bruins got the predators.
We beat the blues the other day.
They gonna put me to sleep.
Oh yeah.
What,
what about when I'm watching your fucking you stupid reality show set.
Huh?
I actually enjoy them.
Right?
I'm not fucking angry anymore.
India.
I try.
I'm trying to keep the anger going.
I don't have it anymore fucking meditating every day.
You know what's funny though is me being less angry is like freaking you out.
It's not freaking me out.
I literally gave you props all yesterday when we after the doctor's appointment
and we sat there and we had a nice brunch and I told you how proud of
used to it used to unnerve me a little bit when you were calm because I just
thought,
what is wrong with you?
I was plotting,
doing something to you.
Oh my God.
Our old friends here in Indochino Indo Chino is one of the largest to measure
men's wear brands and nothing says I'm happy in my relationship.
Like getting some men's wear.
Get a high quality suit made to your exact measurements.
That's the fucking Shit,
man.
When he got a job where you got to wear a suit,
you come home like Hugh Beaumont,
the beginning of leave it to beaver.
Bespoke means for a perfect fit.
Uh,
what's a spoke bespoke?
What does bespoke,
isn't that a suit that's made exact just for you like all of Conor Mcgregor's
suits.
All right guys.
Get some nice suits.
He Dell.
I'll tell you that guy at the only thing nicer than the way knock.
She has the fucking suits he wears.
All right.
You will dress like Conor Mcgregor one day.
I'm gonna make it happen.
Yeah,
and then you'll see exactly how many pounds I need to lose.
The thing about Conor Mcgregor's,
he's in fucking fucking championship shape.
Okay?
I'm at pull,
Lucas shape,
sweatpants and a hoodie.
All right?
You get to,
you get to customize your suit just the way you want it.
Here's how it works.
Visit a showroom,
our shop
online at [inaudible] dot com
pick from hundreds of fabrics.
Choose your cust customization from lapels to pleats to jacket linings and Mora.
That's pretty cool.
You can make a fucking really loud suit or something classy.
Submit your body measurements.
Place you are.
Don't do that.
Don't submit your fucking measurements over the over the Internet.
Don't ever do it.
Do you think online banking is bad?
You submit your body measurements over the Internet.
The fucking Illuminati starts making a robot to your exact specifications and
all of a sudden,
you know,
everybody notices that you're acting weird.
You know you're kind of you,
but you're not you.
That's because the robot's showed up one day and you were like,
hey me,
what are you doing here?
And then it gives you all right there front of you,
fucking,
you know,
chokes you out with your tie that you got from Indo Chad.
All right.
Submit your body measurements,
place your order and wait for it to arrive.
And just four weeks this week,
my lesson is,
can get any Primo Indochino suit for just 389 dollars@indochino.com when
entering burr at checkout,
that's 50% off the regular place price for a man made to measure premium suit
plus shipping is free.
That's indochino.com Chino promocode per for any premium suit for just $389 and
free shipping.
Uh,
it's I,
n d,
It's like China with an o.
It's like outstaying would say China.
I went to Chad.
Um,
incredible deal for a suit that will fit you better than anything off the rack.
Ever could.
Alright.
Oh,
here we go.
Blue Apron,
everybody.
Oh,
blue ball apron,
blue apron.
You know,
not all ingredients are created equal.
No Jesus.
Who wrote this?
That fucking guy Trump just appointed to a attorney general.
You know,
not all ingredients are created equal.
Some of them are.
God locks better.
You know,
they're just smarter.
You know that got better hair.
Oh they,
they,
they sunburn a little bit more my,
maybe they can't pants.
Okay,
I'll give you,
maybe they're better do with Oh,
set shot through the jump shot.
All right.
Fresh high quality ingredients make a real difference.
So important to know.
So it's important to know where your food comes from.
Talk about your personal experience with Blue Apron.
Oh Jesus.
You know,
I always wore white aprons.
Then I put on a blue one and you know,
I felt I felt a little cooler affordable for less than $10 per person,
per meal.
Blue Apron delivers seasonal recipes along with proportion degrees to make
delicious home cooked meals.
I have to tell you this guys,
if you want to fucking lose weight,
if you're working out,
the biggest goddamn thing,
especially become old like me,
is what the fuck you put into your body.
So one of the big pains in the ass,
it's going to the God damn grocery store.
Wouldn't it be wonderful if somebody just brought the shit that you fucking door
all measured out and you can just throw it together after you work out?
Wouldn't that be fucking perfect?
Wash the pounds,
go away.
Suddenly,
you know,
all of a sudden it's like you're going around the world looking over.
All of a sudden you can finally see the head of your Dick again.
You know,
Oh my God,
you're like Christopher Columbus,
okay.
And you and you and your junk is the fucking West indies.
Um,
do we really have to read all of this?
It's their fucking incredible meals.
Okay.
Check out this week's menu and get your first three meals for free with free
shipping by going to blue apron.com/ [inaudible] you will love how good it feels
and tastes to create incredible home cooked meals with blue apron.
So don't wait.
That's blue apron.com/burr blue apron.
A better way to cook,
um,
each meal step by step.
You know that shit customized recipes.
They got varieties.
They got a different fucking recipe every goddamn day.
All right,
lift everybody.
L Y,
F,
T.
Lifed.
You know about Lyft,
right?
This is like when you're in eighth grade,
somebody brings up something,
you know something about sex.
You know what that means,
right?
You're like,
yeah.
What does it mean?
Um,
it's the APP that gets you arrived in minutes on demand 24,
seven for less than the cost of a cap.
Please include all of the following points during your read.
Of course,
I will.
Um,
oh,
you're back.
I'm back.
I was worried you went and just had a baby and see the bathroom.
If you try and lift,
you know what I mean?
With Lyft,
you just download the APP requested driver and they show up in three and a half
minutes on average
fucking sweating,
all coked up.
That's really fast.
Every driver delivers every,
every Lyft drivers fully vetted through their 10 point safety standard.
Yeah.
Unlike those other cuts,
once you got ahead and fucking hands and feet in a foot to step on the gas
pedal,
you got a job over there including criminal and DMV background checks.
You know,
you'll get around quickly and safety lift drivers are rated after every ride.
So only the best stick around.
You don't have to worry about getting into a filthy car with some creepy dude
like they do over there.
Um,
I kids say the name of them,
but it rhymes with boober.
Justin boober
girl,
you know you're the one for me.
[inaudible] let's boy band shit right there with Lyft,
you can tip in the APP,
which obviously leads to happier drivers.
Nine out of 10 Lyft riders get a perfect five star rating.
That's because most people are too mean to give a 10 unlike rich like rex reed,
right?
No,
there too mean to not give a tip.
Sorry.
Some sort of Gong show shit just fell into my head.
Bigger isn't always better.
People lift isn't the biggest ride sharing app,
but it's the fastest growing in the highest rated one.
I'm talking quality over quantity.
Thanks to lift,
you got an easy way to avoid drunk driving.
You never have to bum a ride.
You never have to worry about parking is so perfect for fucking la.
I'll tell you that right now.
A lot of people are actually getting [inaudible],
getting rid of their drivers,
the cars,
and relying on Lyft to get around.
This is a brutal read.
Sorry.
And you know what?
I don't blame them.
Well,
how the fuck do you know what a white blame?
I don't.
It's a nice guest lift.
All right.
Right now,
Lyft is offering our listeners a special deal.
Get three free rides,
up to $10 each.
That's up to $30 value when you enter Promo Code Burr.
Just download the free Lyft app today and wait,
that's confusing.
Lyft is offering our listeners a specialty and get three free rides up to $10
each.
Oh,
so they take you around the block.
We all right,
we want to go to the store that's going to cost you money.
All right.
Um,
where am I?
Promo Code Burr Bill Burr.
Enter Promo Code Bill Barr at their website,
whatever the fuck it was that I said that was that,
was that a good read?
How come they don't have the,
they don't have their website in their,
do they do you know I had an idea the other day.
Nia,
can you believe that I had an idea.
You,
you for what?
Um,
I want to buy like a 1948
like Cadillac limousine.
Okay.
I have the whole,
just whenever that fucking have the interior looked nice,
however,
the outside of the car,
whatever.
Okay.
Then you get the powertrain,
the Sh air shocks.
I'll let shit,
gas monkey the whole fucking thing up.
Right.
And then I get a fucking,
I get a driver,
right?
So I never have to deal with la traffic again.
I just jump in the back.
I got a little fucking bar,
I've got a little humidors,
some cigars and then I got a little Wifi so I can get hammered,
smoke a cigar to some business calls.
And then anytime the as right around the city all day.
No,
anytime I want to go out cause out here,
the big thing with La is this no place to park.
Like you pull into a strip mall that has like 10 fucking businesses and they
have like,
you know 15 parking spots right.
And they tell the employees,
not the park there,
but you know they're going to park there and there's never any place to park.
Sure.
If this guy just pulled up lap way parkway it and I just got out,
then he fucking drove away.
How much you think it would cost to have to have a driver?
Does the driver on calls?
They have a fucking driver.
Like I mean it just sits down the street like a creep.
Read the fucking newspaper.
I think there's a lot of holes in this fucking thing.
A few hundred bucks a day for sure.
Bullshit.
Nobody's going to sit here for fucking 24 hours for 200 bucks.
Yeah,
they wouldn't.
Car Ass.
Yeah.
The other word,
you can definitely hire a private driver that's just on call for you.
You say,
Hey,
can you get here at 10 or whatever.
I got to go here,
here and here and just hang out until I need you again.
If you pay somebody enough,
they'll do it.
Why wouldn't I?
You know what?
He's,
I like driving too much,
but there's those times like whenever you go into a fucking game and all that,
I'm basically describing having my own lift,
you know?
Yeah.
Cause I don't like to,
cause now it's just one person who knows where I live.
Where are those other people?
They know where everybody knows where you fucking live and then they fucking
track you.
Yeah.
It's like Justin,
Uber Does Uber.
Those guys do that all the fucking time.
They start tracking you.
Then they listened,
they hack into your phone and they start listening to you eat corn,
beef hash looking at your rave drugs.
Ass Search.
Yeah.
Watching somebody take a straw,
blow cocaine up your ass as you're going like,
hey,
you know,
I don't feel any higher than us.
I guess it was really no reason to do that.
Let's just do it.
There are nasal passages like we did before.
Yeah.
That's like some jackass would've dug back in the day and they would all be
laughing their fucking asses off.
That was the part of the movies.
I could never sure they've done it.
I could never like those parts of the movie where there was,
there was always those parts where they would just do something.
It's like a pubic hair sandwich or put that little toy car up his ass.
Do you think Steve?
Oh,
never had coke blown up his ass.
I mean,
I'm sure if that was this thing for like two weeks now.
I don't think he did that.
He's a very conventional person.
Okay.
The man,
when he steps away from the camera,
he's very conservative.
Right.
I've done stand up with them a couple times.
You fucking great guy said that.
You said he's like a really nice person.
Yeah.
With an incredible fucking like sense of humor.
Right.
Really,
really funny.
Fucking guy.
Um,
all right.
Legal Zoom.
This is the last one.
Everybody.
Legal Zoom start a new year is perfect opportunity day at the bit to hit the
reset button for a fresh start to finally get around to things you've been
putting off for too long.
And Legal zoom.com is where you make it happen.
So whether you take control of your family's future,
whether it's state land,
or finally get your dream business up and running.
Don't let legal questions hold you back.
Sorry.
Just seems like it's always such dry coffee with these people.
It seems you don't,
you let that black dude who does the,
uh,
was it all state Dennis Haysburt.
Yeah.
Dennis Haysburt.
Are you in good hands?
He's Jewish.
I didn't know that.
Let's see.
Was He,
is He Sammy Davis Jr son?
Cause I know he converted.
His last name is Haysburt.
Oh he said he's Berg and Hayes boy.
All right.
The legal world can be challenging to navigate.
That's why legal zoom was created over 15 years ago to provide you with the
tools you need,
the confidence you already have and the know how to wrap up your legal needs.
And since legal zoom isn't a law firm,
you know I have to worry about expensive hourly fees and standing can get legal
advice at flat rates from the network,
from the networks of attorneys in 48 states.
They'll help you with the rightest state plan or answer the questions you have
for running your business.
Call to action,
make 2017 the year you get your life in order and get special savings when you
enter Promo Code [inaudible] at checkout legal zoom.com.
There you go.
All right,
let's end and let's talk about a Meryl Streep's Golden Globe speech.
What did you think about that Nia?
Did you think it was historically accurate?
Was it something that data Dubay said
there was something that I wasn't surprised that she said
she's been a,
you know this,
she does this.
I wasn't mad in it.
I didn't,
I mean,
I don't think I took offense to deal.
Yeah,
I wasn't mad.
Aside from the usual thing of like,
oh good.
Someone who pretends to be somebody else is going to tell us how the world needs
to be run.
All right.
You thought it was a little,
what's your favorite,
what's your new word that you learned?
Oh,
sanctimonious.
He thought it was a little sanctimonious.
I really don't know what that means.
Little holier than now.
I just stood there was always just cringe worthy moments when everyone from,
uh,
Margaret Moore who,
whatever his fucking name is,
Michael Moore,
Margaret [inaudible] and Meryl Streep and all these people.
You've got to be like guys,
you know,
we're living in a really dangerous time right now.
I just really think it's really important for us all to hold each other and your
love ones a little bit closer.
Just that it's filler.
It's fucking filler.
It's just filler.
I just don't,
I don't,
I don't fucking buy it.
And then in the end you fucking attack bread and circus,
you know,
football and MMA.
Yeah.
Like we're all a bunch of movies and I like MMA.
How come?
They have to be separate?
But,
um,
the majority of her message I thought,
I mean it is an art form,
Huh?
Defending yourself as an art form from debating Marshall are the way to that
spinning kick the Oregon can do.
Um,
yeah.
Well,
like I said,
this is,
you know,
Meryl and are there actors like her?
They have a platform and they feel passionate about it and so they speak on it
yet you give me one instance,
anything wrong with that?
Give me one fucking cause and I'll give you this speech right now off the top of
my head with every fucking cliche and I would be called brave.
If anybody gave a fuck about me,
could give me a topic.
Well,
what do you care about?
No,
you,
that's not the point.
The point is giving me something.
I don't even know anything about it.
I could still give the speech,
oh,
I'm saving the whales.
You know,
when you look at the earth from space,
which so few of us get the chance to do,
like I did in this movie when I pretended to be an astronaut,
most of it is water.
And the biggest thing in the water are whales.
And like us,
they also communicate.
And just because we don't understand them,
let me finish.
Just because we don't understand
them does not mean that they are not saying something and they do not deserve a
voice that needs to be heard.
And despite the current administration,
I,
Bobby,
continue fighting for these whales.
Thank you.
Sorry,
I kind of petered out,
but you don't want to be nice.
Still fucking did it.
I still did it and then maybe the next day it was so brave.
I loved his calm Bourbon.
You know,
he was glowing.
He thanked his wife,
he thanked the whales,
he took a shiny thing and then he fucking,
you know,
I dunno.
Took a fucking stretch SUV Bernan low lead fucking gas into the fucking sunset,
right?
Yeah.
I just don't,
I don't,
I don't give a flying fuck.
I don't need a fucking lecture from an actor on what's going on.
I didn't feel like a lecture.
It just felt like she was passionately talking about something that she felt
strongly about.
Then you know what if Hillary Clinton got in,
who fucking blew the bankers in 2008 do you think she would have given a speech
about that?
No.
How many people that they've crushed?
How many people are upside down in a fucking house right now?
No.
You wouldn't have given speeches.
Of course she wouldn't have wiped because she wears a blue bra and fucking Trump
was fucking red underwear.
It's fucking stupid.
It's like,
listen to the Yankees and red sox fans.
I don't know.
I'll be on it,
but this has been this podcast
and I want you guys to know I don't feel that I'm any different than you.
I'm walking around right now.
I've got special.
Okay.
I'm just a person that decided to listen to themselves and I feel that that's
what everybody needs to do and let's not put for teaching in the educational
system.
Do you not have something that you feel strongly about that you wouldn't maybe
use your platform to discuss?
There's a bunch of Shit I feel strongly about,
but I don't feel like I'm the fucking be all end all in my opinion.
What did you do?
You don't have to be the be all end all,
but you have a podcast that you do twice a flight,
the flight gate,
so fucking passionate about that.
So you have two times a week where you have a guaranteed audience of thousands
upon thousands of people listening to you something.
If I started going Meryl Streep Finish Times a fucking week,
I would have no podcasts podcasting,
but no one would be,
listen,
let me finish.
You're being rude and being rude.
Fake News,
and you had a chance to talk about like,
Hey,
this is the thing that I really feel strongly about.
I feel like people should know.
I want to share.
You don't.
You don't think that you should do that?
No.
Oh,
okay.
Well there you go.
How dumb are people?
They don't know what's important.
People know what's important.
People are not dumb.
I've traveled around people.
I guess I don't walk around people like,
Oh my God,
Bill,
talk slower.
I can't get my head around.
Your phone's.
Not that.
It's not about like patronizing people.
It's like,
Hey,
here's this thing that came up recently.
This is how I feel about it.
I feel strongly about it and here's why.
Maybe you feel this way too.
Maybe you didn't know about this issue.
Maybe this will maybe help you open up a little bit more about it.
Hey,
that's a great delivery.
Somebody ought to try that sometime.
Are you making fun of me?
No.
Meryl Streep was not delivering it that way,
right?
Well,
she was wagging her fucking finger.
She wasn't wagging.
She was getting a lifetime achievement award and she got up there and
[inaudible].
What will you win for you in this year?
Nothing.
I like,
why is she gonna like they've given her every fucking trophy out there.
They've got to get another one.
Yeah,
she's Meryl Streep.
Listen,
she gets all the awards,
you know?
Okay,
okay.
Let me,
I'm not saying she should get the fucking awards,
but why can't you?
But why does it bother you so much that she gets up there and she talks about
what she's passionate about?
It doesn't bother me so much.
I'm just choosing to make fun of it.
Oh,
that's all.
Okay.
I find it just cringeworthy when I,
I don't fucking want to listen to,
uh,
you know,
Georgia Kennedy talked to me about the fucking ozone layer,
he just passed away.
You know what I mean?
Charles Bronson for your fucking,
well,
the thing is you're not being on award shows period.
I think they're silly.
Right.
And then the speed,
I understand why you have to do it.
I think a lot of people that go to them go to them because you have to,
right.
Cause you have to,
cause what it is is you go in there like,
uh,
you know,
you got to support the project that you're in.
Like if that's the family gets fucking nominated for something,
I would go yeah,
when I go up there fucking stand up there or a deck of day with the area.
But I mean you gotta do it.
Yeah.
You have to do it cause that's,
that's part of the thing that you signed up for.
Uh,
it's,
you know,
if,
if it wins Shit,
the writing staff,
they make more money because then they get to be like,
oh wait,
you know,
I wrote on an Emmy Award winning show.
What are the fucking an SB,
whatever the fuck you get.
Right.
You have to play the fucking game.
Yes.
So just go up there.
It say thank you.
I appreciate it.
Take your shiny thing and take a fucking walk like this.
The thing I don't like Trump.
Okay.
I don't like the fucking shit he's doing.
I don't like the people he's picket,
but I don't need Meryl Streep's like once I sit there like,
oh wait a minute.
It's not like,
oh,
thank you Meryl Streep.
Thank you for squeegeeing my fucking third eye.
I know,
I think it's say,
uh,
I think it's one of those things where you're famous too fucking long and you
just start thinking that was like everything that you're doing is a little more
important that it is.
You know what I mean?
I have to be honest with India,
like before I got into this business,
no one ever like,
I'm trying to think like a,
at least using that technique,
no one ever influenced me.
Like I like,
um,
there's people that influenced me like,
oh,
I want to listen to more of that music or uh,
oh wow,
there's,
there's a part of the world like that.
I'd like to see that.
But like,
you know,
I actually,
I don't see how like somebody make it like a fucking three minutes speech is
going to have more of an impact than someone that you live your day to day with
or your parents [inaudible] you know,
that's like that gate that doctor Phil Shit.
Like when they solves problems and like to,
while we watch that shit.
Oh right.
We watch doctor Phil too,
dude living in the truck.
Oh.
And we have watched like judge Judy,
we had a whole like stay at home mom day.
This dude,
this dude was living in a truck with his kid and at night he was in during the
night,
he was in a shelter and they drove around in the truck and it was just,
and it wouldn't scale with this two year old.
I'm getting him like Gatorade and sodas and stuff,
and he goes,
you know what?
Sometimes the kid doesn't eat,
but you know,
I always try to make sure,
you know,
I,
I feed him when I can make sure he's got plenty of sugar and caffeine.
He said,
yeah,
you did that.
That like,
that was a fuck.
Like,
that was good.
He doesn't get,
he doesn't get them like bottles of water.
He gets some Gatorade and Coca Cola.
This is how much that kid look fine now.
And they never showed us say no.
That was the music thing.
It,
that was the music.
Oh,
he looked like a feral animal roaming around and we said he literally a cute
little kid.
Yeah,
he did.
But he also looked like a little,
I don't know.
Kids are dirty,
not market.
I'm going to tell you something right now.
That kid's going to be able to figure out shit more than most of these Goddamn
millennials,
you know that sat there with their clean fucking fingernails.
Lice,
free heads in their fucking laptops.
Plates.
We heads.
All right,
I got to get on with my day here.
Um,
all right,
that's it.
That's a podcast to the movie.
Let's all go to the lobby.
Let's all go to the lobby and the gate.
What we did on the elliptical.
Alright,
go fuck yourselves.
Have a nice weekend.
You can't tell.
Talk to you on Monday.
Okay.
[inaudible] the chin.
Awesome.
Eventually fading into
these
touch.
You
go to
Toc.
Stay Vama listing both for the thing carries every,
I invest in
that firm.
The
Monday morning podcast,
and this is something I have to start off.
I gotta start right out of the gate talking about,
because someone had,
someone was bitching at me that they liked my page,
but they couldn't,
they couldn't shut off my podcast so they could watch the other videos.
If you are new to my page and you're listening to this podcast and you're
already bored with it,
all you gotta do is just scroll down.
It's right in the right hand side and there's a little x.
See this,
click on it.
You'll burn half a calorie donuts and then you can do whatever else you want to
do on the site.
All right?
Okay,
Bruce,
can you figure that out?
Um,
anyways,
what's going on?
How are you?
How was your week?
Do you have a nice week everybody?
I actually had a great fucking week.
I'll show you.
When people do that,
they ask you about something and they don't really give a fuck.
They just setting it up so they can talk about it.
It's like I knew I had an awesome week.
So rather than just coming out and being braggadocious,
if that's even a fucking word,
and just saying I had an awesome week,
I had to actually act like I was a considerate human being and remotely gave a
fuck about what your week was like.
I had an awesome week.
This is what I want to get to.
You don't want to and people do that and then you start to talk about your week
and then they start doing that.
Nod that,
wrap it up.
That really hyper quick fucking chipmunk nod like Eh,
maybe a little circular motion with the left hand lane.
Let's get to the point so I can get on and just download all my shit on the your
spirit.
All right.
Wow.
What an intro.
That's not going to make me want to listen to this.
Anyways,
this is basically my awesome week.
I went to the Improv in Tampa,
Florida.
I have to say that just in case there's a city in Ohio also named Tampa cause I
know they have Miami,
Ohio.
Just fucking hilarious.
Goddamn frozen state.
I live in West Palm Beach,
Florida.
No Ohio sit outside of Dayton.
Um,
yeah,
so I was,
I cannot begin to tell you guys how much dread I was looking at my first two
gigs of this year,
Tampa,
Florida and Houston,
Texas.
Both cities I was looking at with dread.
I'm still looking at Houston with dread.
Why you ask?
Is it because you don't like Tampa bill?
It is you got something against the oil makers in Houston?
No,
it's because the last time I went to both those towns combined,
I think one people came up to came out to see me,
you know,
and I'm to,
I'm not going to lie to you guys,
I'm an older fellow at this point and,
uh,
going on the road can be hard sometimes and if you don't believe me,
just talk to that Filipino who's singing for journey.
He's already bitching fucking little pussy.
You believe that guy fucking guy's singing karaoke in a third world country and
now he's playing the Goddamn fucking La Forum and he's complaining about how
lonely the road is
because he's been out there for fucking six weeks.
Jesus Christ.
You know,
I can't tell if that guy is just a whiny little cunt or fee or fees of fucking
maybe just knows who he is and he can actually step outside of this gun.
You know,
dude,
I really just wanted to fucking sing karaoke and uh,
you know,
singing with you guys was awesome and I'm over it because I know it really makes
me happy.
My friends and my family and making little Bok Choy as I squat in my hut or
whatever the fuck it is that they do over there at typical American.
But I don't know where you're from.
You know,
I think you squatting in a hut eaten Bok Choy.
I don't even know.
Bought [inaudible] and I've had it.
I think it's Korean.
Is that Kimchi?
Um,
we'll have a fuck that guy.
You know what I mean?
Why can't he just be honest and just be like,
you know what?
Um,
I thought I liked journeys music when I was singing it once every other Tuesday
and um,
King Fung Woo's bar and grill in fucking the Philippines.
But uh,
you know,
singing it every night.
It's kind of fucking boring.
And I'm out here with a bunch of fucking geezers.
We're trying to recapture it.
Some other shit.
And one of them,
the guy on the keyboards are still wearing this tight pants and it's just
something I don't like seeing,
but I don't have enough say in the band being as I'm a fucking contest winner.
Jesus Christ.
Can you imagine the awkwardness on the road?
Like this fucking guy that can,
cause,
you know,
they actually went through all the bullshit that band.
Okay.
They ate fucking spaghetti every God damn week,
whatever the fuck they did,
they lived in a van and they fuck in down by the river and they fucking made it.
You know,
they made it and then they got no big fight with Steve Perry because he thought
he could go on his own making oh,
Sherry and some other forgettable sappy shit.
And uh,
you know,
lawsuits all that behind the music shit.
And now they're back on tour again and they just fucking plucked this guy,
you know,
up out of a tsunami.
And now he's playing the,
and I just don't understand how,
how do you fucking bond?
You know what I mean?
That'd be like me.
Last time I played quarterback,
I think was just fucking some pickup game in eighth grade and all of a sudden
I'm fucking,
you know,
I show up in week,
week 15
for the Baltimore Ravens that are not,
you know what though?
You made the point,
why don't you get back to you a great week.
Hey,
why don't I own up to the fact that I told you guys last week that my,
the Carolina Panthers were my dark horse and I believed in Jake the loan and
what happens like jinxed him?
You heard of the sports illustrated jinx as a new genx and town and you fucking
listening to it.
So my apologies to everybody in Carolina.
Um,
in my mind I'm going to Carolina.
All right,
let me get back to my awesome week 20 ways.
Yeah.
Last time I went to Tampa,
nobody fucking showed up.
And uh,
and it was really disheartening because,
uh,
I think at that point my HBO special was out and that type of thing and that's
when it really just hit me how fucking hard this business is.
And I was really like,
wow,
man,
what the fuck do I have to do?
So I went to Tampa and what happened?
I showed up and a bunch of fucking people showed up and they will great crowds
and I got like,
you know,
a couple,
two or three partial standing ovations.
I was killing it.
I was having a great time after my nuts.
Nice month of rest and relaxation.
A bunch of fan as bitches came out to the club baby.
Um,
not a lot of good looking brothers down there and uh,
and I'd probably drank too much fucking two or three nights
was a good time.
Went on.
That Guy Kyle had show if anybody from that show was listening,
um,
tell him I said thank you.
So fucking great show.
I'm going to listen to how cool this is,
how great the whole week was.
I went in to cow head show right off the bat.
That guy's totally cool right off the bat.
He knows how to give a great interview.
I don't have to do material,
which is vitamin,
everything's flowing.
And then all of a sudden,
out of nowhere,
a guy,
one of my buddies from high school,
when I had season tickets to the patriots in 1989 when they sucked and we used
to all pile in the back of his landscaping truck with the half keg of fucking
beer and a bag of chips.
He fucking calls up,
find out he's living down there.
Next thing you know,
we're on the radio together talking about Shit we did 20 years ago and if that
wasn't cool enough to and an electronic drum kit there and they came out of the
radio break playing the immigrant song and I was on the drums playing fight.
This let's fucking having this total geek moment.
And then I went down to the club and it was fucking,
you know,
I'm not going to say it's packed,
but I got into the upper deck,
you know,
just picture a uh,
just picture and Atlanta Braves game when they finally make it to the fucking,
the,
the NLCS.
That's how full the club.
It's about three quarters full.
Fuck you guys.
I was happy with that.
I thought there was,
I mean nobody down there.
So I want to thank everybody down there.
So Houston,
you've got to come through for me.
Okay.
Want to go up and I play that Improv that's underneath that overpass and that
strip mall where evidently there's a lot of violence.
Who the fuck did the research on that one
anyways?
I have.
So like when you walk into that one,
how it looks like scuff faces,
lobby.
It's just a fucking,
I don't fucking know.
Anyways,
why am I shitting on a club then?
I'm going to,
no,
it's a great time.
It's a great part of town.
And,
uh,
all I know is I got,
I finally got my new wow together and I'm really happy and it's,
it's really,
it's,
it's a if things are going good,
so just fucking come out all right.
For the love of God.
But either way,
even if it sucks,
I'm going to south park guitars,
so I'll still have a good time,
man.
I'm going to go skating at your fucking mall because I'm,
let's say like,
right.
So let's get into the podcast here.
So I have hiked what I have coming up.
I'm going to be at the Improv in Houston and a,
these are the dates,
uh,
22nd 23rd and 24th.
Go to Improv too.
Dot Com for all information.
And I'll be selling my brand new DVD.
I'll be standing there like a fucking jackass in the end cause I have no pride.
Um,
actually I decided something,
um,
that,
you know,
cause there's,
there's a lot of guys who like,
you know,
once they get past a certain level they don't want to stand there selling
merchandise at the end of this show.
Um,
cause you feel like an idiot sometimes.
And um,
I got to admit I don't,
I actually liked kind of meeting people at shows.
Lungs are not drunk morons slapping me too hard in the back and spitting on me
inadvertently.
I don't mind that shit,
but this is something that I'm not doing anymore or at least I want to say I'm
not going to,
um,
who's kidding,
who I'm going to do it because there's nothing worse than bringing DVDs home and
your luggage,
you fucking bag weighs like 80 pounds.
But like I hate when I work at club where I have two shows and however the crowd
walks in,
there's not enough room to have the next crowd stand there and have the other
cloud walk out.
So they send the first crowd out the side door and if you want to sell your
merge,
you're literally standing outside the club.
And I cannot begin to tell you how much of a fucking Moron
I see it in people's eyes too.
When they see me,
like I was doing,
like I was standing outside the Improv in Tampa and they have like,
it's one of those,
you know,
as deals,
they've got like a sports bar,
a movie theater.
It's all like this one little,
they can take an outdoor mall and I'm literally standing there and people are
going,
excuse me,
people who don't give a fuck about the show,
who have no idea who I am and an audience members who like give a shit,
who I am really see where I am in this business in that moment is some plumber
just goes,
hey,
uh,
a pasty,
why don't you get the fuck out of their way so I can go see a,
well,
you know,
oh my God,
what Benjamin,
this is going to be a disjointed podcast.
I don't give a fuck,
right?
I'm on some new diet.
I fucking just had eight egg whites.
I'm never doing that again man.
It's just fucking brutal.
I saw that movie Benjamin Buttons.
Bill.
Can you stick with the subject?
Yeah.
So that's what I'm saying.
I don't want to fucking stand outside of club and do that shit anymore.
Okay.
I'll stand in the club and there's a table,
you know,
I leave and make the change.
I don't give a shit,
but I think I'm going to draw the line at,
I'm not going to stand outside of venue dealing with the elements and people on
their way to a fucking Applebee's as I try to Hawk my merchandise because,
uh,
I gotta admit I felt,
I felt,
uh,
they'll pretty a pretty pathetic,
pretty fucking pathetic.
So,
um,
anyways,
let's,
let's get on.
Let's get on with the podcast here and remind me to talk about led Zeppelin
later.
I Dunno,
how are you going to do that?
So I might as well talk about it now.
I'm pretty devastated because I fucking loved that group and I had heard rumors
and I kinda knew they had a couple of blues songs that they reworked in air
quotes and they didn't quite give people credit for it.
And,
uh,
evidently it goes way beyond that and there's some stuff on youtube.
I'm always looking at led Zepplin shit cause I'm a huge John Bonam fan and
somehow I stumbled across this thing cause I guess the Youtube Guy was just on
Howard stern so there was a lot of shit on them or bought them stealing
material.
And uh,
all I can say is wow,
it went beyond a couple of songs.
It went into,
I mean every song but two songs and their first album,
half the songs on their second album,
they're even trying to say that they ripped off the intro to stairway to heaven.
They had like an opening act on tour with them.
I just,
I dunno,
I don't know how to process it.
And not only that,
I just brought my,
bought my nephew the fucking box set the entire digitally remixed remastered box
set of led Zepplin for Christmas.
You know,
thinking I'm the cool uncle and I just gave him a,
uh,
a box of stolen shit that's just fucking brutal.
Check out that Jeff Beck album truth.
I just downloaded it.
How many more times?
He literally takes a section straight up from the guy,
but you know,
I think that's on those other guys.
They should've just fun.
You know,
you know what it is.
You can't do anything.
It's nothing you can do about it.
They fucking steel and they get credit and they get taken into the hall of fame
is fucking brutal.
All right.
That was a bummer.
Did I just say a bummer but actually kind of work cause I was talking about
music from the 60s that was a bummer man.
What a drag.
Um,
all right.
Anyways,
so last week I got up on my soapbox a little bit or my Ottoman,
if you want to get technical.
And
I was talking about last week how I'm sick of going into these places of
business and with this new technology,
they're firing fellow Americans and they're making me do the,
the fired employee's job.
And to me that is not progress.
All right?
That is a adding another person out there who's going to be competing for me for
a job while I do their fucking job for free.
So I asked people what they thought about that shit.
You know what I'm talking to specifically about going into a grocery store and
they want me to check myself out.
Okay.
As if I'm somehow going to do it faster than a cashier.
That seems to be the illusion here that that makes it faster.
You know what I mean?
Somebody who actually works there and does it 9,000 times a day so they can only
have to look at the fucking keyboard.
Goddamn Stevie wonder,
fucking blowing through it,
you know?
And somehow I'm going to be quicker than that,
So anyways,
I asked people what they thought about it and uh,
I got interesting.
I got to,
you know,
basically I took two of them that kind of summed up everybody's shit.
And then I switched up some of the guitar parts and I called it stairway to
heaven.
No,
wait a minute.
All right.
Um,
somebody said,
I agree with you.
New Technologies often make certain jobs obsolete,
but they also create new ones.
And this case.
I don't think there are enough low level jobs out there to start getting rid of
cashiers.
Um,
yeah,
I definitely agree with you.
I,
I don't feel like
they're making you,
you're walking into the grocery stores,
the customer,
they're making you be a cashier for free and everyone's sitting there going,
oh,
it's quicker.
This is what this guy is,
this guy saying this guy's trying to go bill.
As far as the self checkout line and grocery store,
I can't agree with your take on the situation.
Any place I have seen with self checkout lines still have regular lines as well.
Can you believe that point?
Any place I've seen with self checkout lines still have the regular lines as
well.
Obviously they're just not overnight going to get rid of everybody.
They're teaching you how to be a cashier for free and once we all get it down,
eventually they're going to get rid of everybody the same way they're doing it
with like those toes,
those easy tasks,
things that you know,
never.
There was only one easy pass line.
Now it's down.
There's only one toll booth line.
And sometimes you get off the exit.
There's no toll booth.
You just bet I have the fucking right amount of change.
You know?
I guess that does make it easier but also let them know where the fuck are you
are.
Which annoys the shit on me but I wasn't bitching about that dude.
The only reason why 10 out of 10 lines are not automated is because it's a new
technology and that's why they have the douche standing there teaching you how
to fucking use.
They teaching you how to be a cashier so they can fire other cashiers and then
they don't have to pay and you as the customer who used to just come up with
your food and stand there and rubbed your fucking balls looking around.
I mean don't you understand the arrogance of that?
Hey,
why don't you come into my store,
pick up what you want.
You figure out what the fuck you all me pay me stick you stick it in the bag and
then get the fuck out of my store.
You'll find a problem with that.
Anyways,
this guy continues to say,
I don't think anyone is losing any jobs or that grocery stores are going to turn
into self serving only venues.
I'm sorry,
but I'm going to stand in La.
I'm not going to stand in line behind the soccer mom who's buying enough
groceries to last the entire winter.
Meanwhile,
all I got is a box of cereal,
cereal and milk,
and now I have to tell myself I'm doing a good thing for the workforce by Resu
refusing to serve myself and the self checkout line.
Not In this lifetime.
My fine feathered friend,
he really thought he made a great point there.
What do you know what?
I think you're a retard.
What do you think about that?
Who stands in line in front of behind somebody who's got enough fucking
groceries for the winter when all you have is a box of cereal and milk?
Have you ever heard the express checkout eight items or less?
Have you never noticed that?
I don't.
You know what,
that,
that uh,
that is fucking pissed.
That whole thing just piss me off.
You know what get is great dude.
Yeah.
Stand in line and go do a job you didn't have to do before and do it for free
and put somebody outside of work and tell yourself that it's fucking quicker.
The same way they're doing that on TV where they got that commercial and they
try to mind fuck you into thinking that using your ATM card is quicker than
using cash.
You know?
Come on man,
you should fucking head.
You know what they're doing?
They're phasing out cash,
so now there's no more under the table.
Bullshit out there and you're going to get taxed even fucking more,
and they'll know where you are at all fucking times.
That's what they're doing.
All right.
Debit cards are not quicker than cash,
and I love the commercial that they have.
I don't know if they're still running it,
but they literally used homophobia to try to convince you.
You know,
they,
they put into that part of your brain,
Hey,
I'm not sucking Dick.
I'm going to use the fucking debit card.
They basically had this commercial,
they had a bunch of people buying a Steelers jerseys.
I remember they're all buying football jerseys and they'd go in through the line
and everybody's using a debit card and that plane,
that bugs bunny music,
Dun,
Dun Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh.
And everything's going great and it's,
and people are swiping at once and they just grabbing the bag and the whole
transaction takes literally two seconds.
Okay.
Which has not been my experience ever.
The Guy fucking tries to put the password and it doesn't fucking work.
They swipe it three times in.
The cashier finally spins the thing around,
tries to do it themselves.
It's a big fucking pain in the ass.
So anyways,
after all these guys cruise through,
then this,
you know,
buying football,
this fucking guy comes up to buy tennis balls with a pink sweater tied around
his neck and he's piece paying cash.
And the second he takes out the cash,
you know that,
that music just comes to a dead halt and everybody's staring at him.
Get it.
You know,
football men,
tennis,
pink sweater,
Fag.
I just fucking unreal.
I don't know.
You know,
fuck this shit.
I'm just going to go live in the fucking mountains.
I'm tired of trying to convince people.
I had this stupid girl in the front row as explaining the whole fucking thing to
her and she's like,
still told me that the thing that she was going to use the automated checkout at
the cashier at the,
at the grocery store,
cause I go,
why?
She goes Congress cluck.
How?
How has it,
how has it quicker,
you know,
you could teach me how to change your fucking tire.
I'm not going to do a quick and then I'm fucking mechanic or change my oil or
what I don't fucking that,
whatever,
whatever.
Standing those fucking lines.
You've fucking drones.
Oh,
see all childish.
I get when people have a different opinion.
This is why can't sustain a relationship.
Okay,
let's get,
let's get to the question.
You know,
it really is,
I'm just fucking annoyed that I found out that one of the groups that I loved
has stolen all this goddamn music
I to do it.
It just,
you know,
it's funny about led Zepplin too,
is they always had that,
that cheesy shit where they would just like trying to say that they all sold
their soul to the devil.
Everybody sold their soul to the devil except for John Paul Jones.
And that's why all the,
that horrific shit happened.
Like John Bonam died.
Robert Plant got in the car accident and his kid died mysteriously and,
uh,
Jimmy page,
I don't know.
He fucking,
his eyes got all squinty.
I Dunno what the fuck what am to Jimmy page?
He didn't lose a finger.
That was a guy from black sabbath.
Bam did Jimmy page.
He had a castle.
I don't know if somebody,
I'm gonna Jimmy page some.
I haven't bad to everybody,
but you know,
the reason it wasn't because they sold the soul,
it was calmer for stealing all those fucking songs
then inducted into the hall of fame.
All right.
Whatever.
Okay.
Anyways,
you know what?
I should've been more mature about that.
Some people don't fucking agree with me on those,
uh,
those automated lines.
I just,
I know I can me,
it's clear as fucking day.
It's clear as fucking day.
You know I'm not a hundred percent against you like it when I go to the airport.
Sometimes that automated shit is quicker.
Like when you go to check yourself in for a flight,
that's definitely,
definitely fucking quicker.
But when I get on the plane and they started telling me I need to fold up my
blanket to help expedite the cleaning of the cabin,
go fuck yourself.
All right.
That's for the cleaning crew.
I'm sorry they fired the cleaning crew.
I'm not doing that fucking job.
I did my job.
I got on the plane.
I said a prayer on takeoff and landing that we wouldn't crash.
I didn't try to open the emergency door or charge the cockpit.
I'm done.
You know I'm not taking out a fucking lip brush and a crumb bar and cleaning up
my fucking area.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I don't work for the airline.
And we go,
Hey,
and I'm getting a new laptop this week,
so this is the last time you're going to hear that fucking annoying clicking
sound.
I'm trying to do it smoother.
All right,
let's get to the podcast questions for the weekend.
I got to tell you guys,
this is going to be a short podcast this week because,
uh,
I have a ton of shit to do.
Um,
why can't I just be nicer?
I appreciate you guys all listening to my podcast,
but I got through.
I have to go back into there.
The 700 club guy,
you know,
put your hands on your laptop screen.
Let's say praying for cheese.
Um,
no,
I appreciate all you guys listening and all that type of stuff and uh,
it can be blown through it.
Why can't you have a sensitive moment,
Bill?
Why can't you open up?
Okay.
Take a deep breath.
Let it out.
I appreciate the fact that all you guys listen to my podcasts,
but a,
I have a lot of,
um,
things that I have to get done today.
I can't fucking do it.
I got a lot of shit to do.
All right,
question number one.
Uh,
Bill,
you often talk on the cast of how people shouldn't work.
Certain jobs that help the man
fucked in.
Fuck the common folk.
One of my jobs I currently work cause I'm broke is essentially telemarketing.
And I go home from it feeling dirty.
But who's fault is it really mine or the dopes?
I'm fucking and where exactly do draw the line of what jobs to not work
according to your personal standards.
All right.
Uh,
telemarketing.
I mean,
that's not making me do a job.
So I mean,
as,
as annoying as it is.
You can,
you can sign yourself up for that.
Don't call list on the Internet if you guys want to look that up.
I did that and nobody ever fucking calls me.
And uh,
um,
but I mean,
I don't know what you'd telemarketing.
You say you go home feeling dirty.
I'd have to know what it is that you do because you're like,
I feel really guilty,
but who's fault is it?
Mine or the dopes?
I'm fucking so obviously,
whatever you're selling them is bullshit and you know,
it's bullshit,
but you're telling them that it's,
it's great shit.
So,
uh,
who's fault is that?
A,
that's yours.
I'm going to say that's yours.
You know,
you know,
do you know what's yours?
You go home feeling dirty.
Yeah.
Obviously doing some shit you don't want to do.
But I understand any port in a storm,
I don't know if he's selling people sham wows like morons like me and I buy the
fucking things,
you know,
you're not really hurting.
I don't know what the fuck I'd have to know what you're selling.
You know,
if it's selling those fucking mortgages that screwed over this economy,
then you should feel dirty.
But uh,
I dunno,
I don't fucking know.
I'm trying to think.
You know something I used to tell the market so I can't judge you.
I used to sell newspapers,
subscriptions over the phone and you know,
when you're just doing that sort of cold calling,
the only weapon you have is to lie your ass off.
And the only way I got through it was trying to make the guy next to me laugh.
I used to go by Bill Macdonald and uh,
the other guy,
what the fuck did he get?
One of the guys I worked with actually went by the name Keith Crowder,
who was the name of one of the guys who actually played on the Boston Bruins and
we were in Boston.
He used to call people up,
hey,
how you doing?
This is Keith crowd or calm from the Boston globe.
And people would just,
every once in a while so it'd be like,
oh yeah,
Keith Crowder.
They'd be like,
Oh yeah,
you play for the Bruins and [inaudible] view the guy that's my cousin.
Or he would just say that,
oh yeah,
I get that all the time.
You know what I mean?
Like if your name was actually Barry Manilow or some shit,
um,
I don't know,
Dude.
I'm not trying to make you feel guilty.
I would just try to get out of that fucking job.
But dude,
if he can't get out of that job,
I mean,
w what do you,
what are you going to do?
And all depends on what you're doing,
dude.
50 if it's,
if it's stealing from old ladies and taken that their life savings and uh,
you know,
I had a buddy of mine was doing something like that and he ended up in jail.
So you better watch out whatever you're doing.
Um,
you know what?
I'm really feeling like I'm fucking getting preachy and righteous here.
Um,
you,
I a,
I don't know shit.
Just know that I don't read,
you know,
even all that shit I just said about led Zeppelin,
actually,
you know what,
that wasn't just youtube shit I watched on youtube and this kid had the music to
back it up.
So,
but anything else is a,
that comes in on our mouse mostly is bullshit.
All right,
question number two.
Uh,
Bill,
is there any way to get links to the individual podcast?
I try to subscribe,
but I don't think it worked.
I'm not really as retarded as a computer makes me look.
I could not identify with you more.
That's exactly what happens to me every time I tried to watch or listen to
anything on the,
on the computer and I have no idea.
I don't know how to help you.
I really don't.
Um,
I'm like,
I dunno.
what the fuck is that,
that that holiday in commercial,
you know,
now I don't know.
I don't know computers,
but I stayed at a Holiday Inn last night and Holiday Inn express or whatever the
fuck it is.
That's how I am.
You know,
I'm on the computer,
I know how to put up a podcast,
but I don't know how to do any of that other stuff.
So anyways,
listening has this information and what's the email or to certainly I read it
next week and I'll pass it off as my own.
Just like Jimmy page.
Squinty eye contact.
All right.
Question number three,
Bill.
You must get a ton of podcasts,
questions and overrated,
underrated stuff.
How do you decide which ones to use in your podcasts?
Um,
I basically any anytime somebody,
if it's a repeat question,
um,
like I,
I try to ignore those,
but once every six I will answer the question,
how did you get involved in stand up?
But,
um,
and then just,
yeah,
they're good questions.
I feel like I can go off on them and they have funny than that.
That's basically how I do it.
But if it's a slow week,
I'll read every goddamn one of them cause I don't get a ton of them.
I get like a dozen or so,
so a,
so if you have a question,
are you thinking like,
Oh man,
he's saying that really need in chances are,
I will read it.
You got an 80% chance.
How about that?
80% chance.
And that's based on not even mathematically studying it on any level.
All right,
question number four,
Bill.
Have you ever seen two guys start comparing scars?
Are these two guys just a bunch of tools of what?
Usually by the end,
one or the other has pulled up his shirt and pulled down his pants.
What a bunch of fags.
I got to admit,
I've never seen that.
Uh,
do you hang out in a pirate bar?
I have no idea.
That would be weird.
I,
yeah,
that's kind of awkward.
Uh,
reminds me of a,
that,
that scene in jaws where they just sit around a,
yeah.
This right here.
Fucking
electric eels at me.
Oh yeah.
This a sting ray stuck me in the nuts,
whatever.
Now I've never seen that,
but I'm,
I the way the picture you painted,
I'd have to agree with your assessment.
You've got to say something like,
why don't you two fucking hacked up pussies?
Pull up your pants please.
For the love of good.
Anyways,
you know what I resent seeing?
I resent seeing a middle aged man who has a smooth chest and that cause they
shaved it just the hair never came in and they got those fucking five daddy long
legs hanging off a one nipple and they don't work out and it's just all just,
it looks like a,
it looks like a melted snowman.
Ah,
that's why I don't,
I'm not a Jew.
I'm not a member of a gym.
All right,
Bill,
have you and Jim Norton never compared to appendix scars?
Uh,
no.
No I haven't.
No.
I,
this is a whole new fucking world that I don't want to get involved in.
This is some sort of,
do they have scar porn?
This is really making me uncomfortable.
Um,
Bill,
besides your appendix scar,
what is your best scar and how did it happen?
All right,
they can answer this one.
I have one right above my left eyebrow that you can only see when,
if I'm imitating the rock.
And how I got it was my older brother threw me off the porch head first and I
landed like a lawn dart into a flagstone.
This is basically,
it is basically the story.
We had a,
you have a,
you know those,
those,
those porch swings that they have back in the day where,
uh,
if you,
if you came,
according back in the day you'd come and they,
they wouldn't let you go anywhere.
So you'd said,
I don't know,
on a spring and I was on a swing.
It's like basically a love seat,
but it's a swing and he'd sit out there and sing like lighter rose or something.
Lot of rose.
I'm home again.
Rosie barbershop quartet would show up like in the music man.
Yeah,
we had one of those.
So somehow my brother pissed me off and he was swinging like a fucking maniac on
that thing.
So I grabbed,
I think it was a rake.
I don't know that it's not important what the business end of it was because
it's really,
this story is about the handle of whatever I grabbed.
So it's a brome,
it's a rake.
I don't know what the fuck it was.
And as when he got up to the top,
I stood underneath him like I was in 300 you know,
and I just held that stick up and I fucking caught him right in his stomach.
And I held them for probably like half a second.
And then I dropped the broom handle,
whatever.
And I turned around and I went to run off of the porch and he had the momentum
of the swing coming down.
So he immediately was like right behind me.
Like you have a watch,
the roadrunner and the coyote,
when coyote chases the road runner road around,
it goes flying by him and he's at a dead stop.
And somehow he catches all the way up to them,
except for the last three feet.
That's what the fuck my brother did.
But he had the aid of a swing.
So I'm right at the top step of the porch and he just sort of pushed me in the
middle of my back little Claude Lemieux action.
Right?
And that's when I just went fucking airborne.
And,
uh,
I don't know if I ever told you this guys the size of my huge head right now.
I had this head when I was,
it was the same size when I was born,
so I was probably 11 years old.
So let's,
you know,
for the sake of the story,
I'm fucking top heavy,
right?
So I immediately start going down like a fucking javelin and it happened so
fast.
I couldn't get my hands out knee if I could.
I would've broke both my wrists trying to stop terminal velocity of my skull and
I just fucking went head first into this flagstone and uh,
had a nice gash.
Actually took out a little chunk of my skull,
a little sliver of it,
of my Frankenstein brow.
And,
uh,
I just remember getting up and I went back up to the top of the porch and I was
leaning over the banister cause I didn't want to start bleeding in the house
cause I knew my dad was gonna Freak out cause he already had to stitch me up.
My Dad's a dentist,
so,
uh,
it's Kinda cool.
Anytime you got stitches,
you,
you didn't have to go to the hospital.
He just fucking,
it was like,
oh,
like in between periods they just saw you up on the bench.
He just do it right there and we,
you know,
it's funny,
we always ended up having to get stitches on his day off.
Pull pass did used to work like three weeks in a row we get one day off and then
one of us would fall out of a tree or accidentally in air quotes,
throw a fucking rockets.
You know,
I did that one.
And uh,
we always use the same excuse.
I was running through the woods and I tripped and he'd be like,
Oh for Christ's sake,
I don't need this shit
any fucking Uda.
He just lays down on the sofa,
you know,
numbers up and he'd start stitching this up and we'd be going out and he'd be
like,
come on,
stop it.
Stop it.
That doesn't hurt that bad.
And uh,
yeah,
then you'd have a fucking scarf.
There you go.
That's my uh,
do I have any other ones?
I got bit in the face by my own dog.
That was a good one.
Where this little West Highland terrier and uh,
we just kept fucking with them.
Um,
I dunno why.
I can't even remember why at this point.
I'm still fucking longer.
We basically turned them into an attack dog.
We started off just rough housing with him and then he would bite.
It's a little too hard.
And then we moved on to a garden gloves and we started playing what be called
the glove game and we've just keep pushing them in the face and then he figured
out how to bite.
So then we moved on to,
I think like hockey sticks and we,
you know,
wasn't hit them really hard.
We just sorta like,
actually you don't need trying to dig out the puck in the corner.
We kind of do that shit.
And He'd start biting at it.
And I remember when he,
when he would bite down on it and he finally learned to start shaking it going
like,
oh,
doing that shit.
We thought it was the funniest shit ever,
you know?
And we were all like,
ages two to 10,
you know,
this is back in the day too,
when,
you know,
there was no Oprah Winfrey,
so people didn't know that you shouldn't leave fucking five kids under the age
of 10 at home with a dog and electricity,
you know?
And uh,
so yeah.
So we just turned this down into a fucking attack though.
Can we do clearly taught him how to bite.
And we all thought it was hilarious until he started doing it to us.
And,
uh,
so one day my brother is sitting on the couch and he's eating a sandwich and my
dog sitting there setting up begging,
you know,
little shit,
little terrier.
So I start crawling up next to him just going,
hey,
I'm going to get to food.
I'm going to get their food.
He's sitting there on her.
He keeps looking over at me and I just kept creeping up going,
I'm going to get the food.
And then he started doing like that half a fucking smile,
show me his fangs and we're laughing,
laughing.
That's always do just drive him fucking the same way we do to my little brother,
just piss him off.
It was just fun to watch somebody lose this shit.
And uh,
the dog was no exception.
And then I don't know what happened.
I took it too far and he just lunged over to bite me.
And I was,
my face was at his face,
his level,
and he just grabbed me on the same side,
same side.
When my brother threw me off the porch,
he fucking sunk in just below my eye into my cheek.
And then one of his lower canines was actually inside my mouth and he had my
entire fucking left cheek.
And he went
and he knew he fucked up too because he's bit me on the leg and he didn't give a
fuck.
But when he did down when he was like,
oh shit,
that's easily a 10 minute misconduct if not in fucking game suspension.
Um,
yeah.
And that was a,
that was a,
that was a rough walk into the bathroom.
I remember that.
Oh,
I get hurt.
It kind of felt like a,
I was just like,
ah,
I was worried I was going to be deformed.
So that was the thing.
Like I was going to look in the mirror.
I was like,
oh my God,
am I gonna look like a,
like somebody just got bit in the face by a fucking terrier and somehow I did.
He kind of,
they were like puncture wounds.
I still see him,
man.
I'm looking in the mirror right now.
It kind of faded away,
but that the one on my upper lip,
I don't fucking know.
But then I had to go to my dad's office and he was already working on other
people,
so he was pissed and it was also embarrassing the next day when I went to
school,
you know,
face is all bruised up and I had stitches he face and I was like,
God,
I got bit by a dog who's dog?
Oh my dog.
And like,
did you get rid of it?
No.
Why not?
Because my family is fucked in the head.
What do you think?
You know,
do I sound supposed to do that shit?
It's supposed to,
you know,
chase frisbees and be skipping along with you as you walked back from catching
catfish.
Right.
And that's supposed to bite you in the fucking face,
but you know,
I deserved it.
So there you go.
There's my scar stories for the week.
Um,
I didn't get a chance to get to underrated overrated this week.
I'll just add to them next week we'll have a giant,
we'll have a bonus section of underrated overrated because there was some really
good ones this week.
And,
uh,
and that is it.
Um,
what do I got?
What he got a hyper real quick.
Oh,
please.
Uh,
please come see me at the Improv in Houston,
Texas.
Um,
go to Improv,
the number two.com or you can click on the link.
Went on my homepage and a Boston.
I got my big trip back to Boston in February 6th and I'm not trying to be a
cheeseball here,
but tickets are fucking this selling like hotcakes
and such a ridiculous fucking statement that's selling like hotcakes really.
Who came up with that?
You know,
you know what?
I'm never gonna I'm gonna,
I'm really gonna try to explore that comedically,
because that is just such a hacky,
like want to be Jerry Seinfeld fucking bit,
you know,
some of my card.
Keurig's well,
what's the deal again?
We're very crude and
um,
I like I said,
I wasn't going to do that and then I just did it.
What do you think about that?
You know,
so right now you guys should just be shutting up the podcast because I've
obviously establish the fact that,
that I'm not a man of my word.
You know,
I worked with this comedian,
Ryan Dalton this weekend and I was going to do something.
I really fucked it up.
I was meaning to try to get some girl to show her tips at the end of this show.
And we were trying to come up with a way to do it.
You know,
I was going to do it in a silly way.
Like,
come on man,
the economy's bad,
you know,
just,
just do it for America.
Just make it silly.
And you know,
that'd be one girl will be willing to do it.
And then we try and thinking about like reverse psychology,
like a,
you know,
I had to,
keep it going for Ryan,
isn't he?
If these need a great comedian,
I'll tell you,
but he's really bashful off stage.
The other night,
this girl was shown attached to the,
he just turned all beat red is one of the funniest,
you know,
try to fucking make it look like he's not a little fucking creep,
you,
the reality was was I wanted to see some titties and I was using him as an
excuse
and I kind of forgot to do that.
You know,
I was really upset with myself because if I,
if I miss a joke,
I said,
we've got to do a joke.
I don't give a fuck.
I'll do the joke next show.
But you know,
when you miss out on titties,
you know that one sticks with you.
All right?
That's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
Thank you for listening.
As always.
Uh,
everybody have a great week and a wow.
My Christmas,
she's fucking dead.
This thing is fucking dead.
Cow Dry and brittle.
This thing is,
sorry buddy.
Christmas is over.
All right,
everybody have a good week.
So
[inaudible]
off
the
land on
the long
shot.
Two,
nine,
about two weeks
time on victim to the
[inaudible].
This,
ah,
[inaudible] the dogs.
Is that
[inaudible].